♪ ("THE HUNTER GETS CAPTURED
BY THE GAME" BY THE MARVELETTES
PLAYING) ♪
♪ What's this ol' world
Comin' to? ♪
♪ Things just ain't the same ♪
♪ ("YOU CAN'T BE FUNKY"
BY BUSH TETRAS PLAYING) ♪
NAN GOLDIN: Photography's like
a flash of euphoria,
and it gave me a voice.
Once I started sharing the work,
there was really
heavy resistance...
especially from male artists
and galleries,
who said,
"This isn't photography.
Nobody photographs
their own life."
♪ Dance, dance, dance
Talk, talk, talk ♪
Photographer Nan Goldin, she's
a major name in the art world.
SPEAKER: The work was
incredibly political.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
NAN: Probably my whole life's
a struggle
to fight conformity
and denial.
NAN: (VIA MICROPHONE)
A hundred thousand deaths!
ACTIVISTS:
PATRICK RADDEN KEEFE:
There's the Sackler family
of the art world,
the museum world,
and philanthropy,
and then there's
the Big Pharma marketing,
and addiction, and death.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
NAN:
My anger at the Sackler family,
it's personal.
When you think of the profit
off people's pain,
you can only be furious.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
NOEMI BONAZZI:
Nan said, "I think we should
take these people down,
but do you think
my career will implode?"
And I said, "Probably."
We need to demand
that the Met Museum,
the Louvre, the Tate
refuse donations
from the Sacklers
and take down their name.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
NAN:
The rich people are scared
that we're gonna dig into
the evil way they make money.
ALL: Sacklers lie! Sacklers lie!
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
NAN: When you grow up
being told, "that didn't happen,
you didn't see that,"
how do you trust yourself?
And so that's the reason
I take pictures.
SPEAKER 2:
This is a watershed moment.
People are actually beginning
to rethink how they do things.
ACTIVISTS: Say it loud!
Say it clear!
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
ACTIVISTS: No longer!
No longer! No longer!
NAN: The wrong things
are kept secret in society,
and that destroys people.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪